[Music]
[Music]
greetings [ __ ] no Joey here from
the Garden of Good and Evil this is what
[ __ ] heats up the first ball sack but
that got none to do it uncle Joey here
to spread Chi in love and harmony today
Friday October 21st year swinging dick
and giving our bubble gum as usual
nothing [ __ ] stopping you today I'm
saying this is the last day of the
[ __ ] week you're picking up an
envelope you're showing up with a big
dick and a [ __ ] umbrella you follow
me I'm feeling good looking good as far
as today's control I'm the man of many
reef is always perennial you don't make
these [ __ ] to [ __ ] around and
that's why I rock with them right now
smoke and a footman sativa to get the
SPD door some baubles
I love [ __ ] end
if 17 in the morning what the [ __ ] have
you done today [ __ ] anyway I'm
feeling good I'm looking good I got a
couple of things on tap today I think
I'll be making it to jujitsu I [ __ ]
my back man was [ __ ] with me but now
it's all good I got the [ __ ] special
shot I got rid of the [ __ ] - mattress I
mean more than a [ __ ] Cairo and who's
better than [ __ ] me I'm here I'm
ready to go and I'm ready to rock
what do you say hello Joey do we spark
another bond [ __ ] yeah
it's Friday I can't have you going out
that will [ __ ] up I need job then
committed stone till he kills minding
your own business
yeah eyes open for [ __ ] Isis let's
finish this [ __ ] - I'm telling you
I'm ready to go today I gotta put five
[ __ ] thirty in the morning pit pop
the duke shine my shoes
I put [ __ ] powder on my nutsack today
it's all over you have to stay [ __ ]
focus that's it nice and listen you
gotta be flopping as if not gonna be a
long [ __ ] weekend I'm saying I
already got my map out for next week I
got my [ __ ] goes down for next week
a little week off
but not really it took a week off a
stand-up everything else I'm still in so
[ __ ] tight and today it don't happen
ten o'clock twelve o'clock 3:30 you know
it never [ __ ] stops I got to start
writing this [ __ ] book I've been
putting it together with Gordon that's
all [ __ ] going down so you know man
the struggle never ends it's just how
you [ __ ] pace yourself but enough is
it on Joey's gonna spark that
[ __ ] soldier or what
how you like me now [ __ ] that went
right in your [ __ ] eyeball straight
and direct no drama and look protein
shake this morning a little [ __ ] on
it chocolate who scoops some water
here's some ice cubes who's better than
[ __ ] me I'm saying if not I mean eggs
bacon parentally that [ __ ] today I would
just [ __ ] him doing a protein shake
tomorrow maybe we do two ways for the
sperm sac to keep their yet little
[ __ ] solid you found it
what do we have now oh [ __ ] the
[ __ ] brain free listen I told
you I show up with three guns a machine
gun a [ __ ] yo-yo a [ __ ] tomahawk
you know me Doug you gotta hit him from
all directions the team is then that is
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] explosives foot
fungus powder whatever you got whatever
you need I got
7:30 in the morning were blowing balls
like [ __ ] soldier you understand who
does this type of [ __ ] us the church
family [ __ ] cuz we don't give a [ __ ]
we ain't got time we ain't had time we
gotta get in our head and and go out
there and strike like a [ __ ] snake
look look I'm saying F up around that's
it man
as you could tell I'm stumped am i
ashamed to [ __ ] know what better than
7:30 in the morning out here [ __ ]
salute [ __ ] let [ __ ]
know what time it is on a Friday I don't
have a lunch somebody would be confused
uncle Joey's having a bad day and all
[ __ ] world you're in a bad day we
come out to [ __ ] jump with fire grass
is explosives we don't give a [ __ ] you
understand me we come out to gate every
day [ __ ] up you don't feel good every
day we there when I go in the shower you
don't think I'm gonna go back to the bed
[ __ ] y'all never bite the bed smoke dope
and you [ __ ] jellied them was but you
can't you gotta get that shine in that
shower you mentally but Panama stabbed a
[ __ ] today
just when you thought it was safe
[ __ ] go in there put on [ __ ] Pink
Floyd play it backwards I don't know I
don't give a [ __ ] what you need to get
to get motivated today somebody's out
there they got your [ __ ] lunch money
in their pocket you want to sit there
with your friends that the Simpsons were
great last I don't give a [ __ ]
go get your [ __ ] envelope go get your
[ __ ] lunchbox go live your [ __ ]
life get off that [ __ ] song get off
that [ __ ] Facebook you don't need a
plug in here to walk down the street
with a [ __ ] unit don't be a stupid
[ __ ] friends about what about what
what are you talking about find out this
a-team is like having a [ __ ]
hemorrhoid laughs I'm saying [ __ ] all
right let's do one more and I got [ __ ]
to doing people to see you on this damn
it can't be out here all morning [ __ ]
smoking dope weird [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
Garden of Good and Evil wait should we
face this [ __ ] gorilla cool let's
finish this
faked I don't [ __ ] run a museum here
and here look at Budds and show my
Google look at this one
we [ __ ] smoking here with three
[ __ ] hands am I gonna have to [ __ ]
I'm saying enough is enough Joey
sparked that [ __ ]
[ __ ] tremendous I love you comes up
if you know that without you I got dick
dick next Friday and Saturday the South
Point in Vegas but better yet November
11th and 12th November 11 coming Boston
on the Wilbur [ __ ] Theater and
then Saturday I'm a [ __ ] Fox woods
and Stanley so Friday I'm at the [ __ ]
data
Saturday I'm a fox woods that's it I'm
coming back to him on a legal seafood
I'm doing everything I'm tearing up
[ __ ] Boston like a such November 11th
make sure you there I don't wanna hear
no [ __ ] stories my foot hurt my hand
have a go to that doctor I don't give a
[ __ ] about you and I need you there
slinging smoke and look towards
I don't love you cut sucks I got [ __ ] to
do people to see and places Dakota where
the [ __ ] am I going anyway I love you
Todd suckers
have a great weekend god bless you keep
your eyes open all I nobody [ __ ] with
you uncle Joey loves your podcast Sunday
night 6 o'clock don't worry about that I
got you